das virus und die folgen drei weitere
infizierte in bayern und ein deutliches
signal
die lufthansa streicht alle flüge von
und nach china bis zum 9
februar neue aufgabe für die
bundesfamilienministerin franziska
giffey will an die spitze der berliner
landes spd michael müller bleibt aber
zunächst regierender bürgermeister
starker auftritt in melbourne
alexander zverev erreicht nach einem
eindrucksvollen sieg gegen den schweizer
stan wawrinka zum ersten mal ein grand
slam halbfinale
[Applaus]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten um 7 den sport hat
wieder norbert lehmann dabei
schönbrunner formiert das corona virus
sorgt weiter für schlagzeilen in bayern
gibt es nun insgesamt vier fälle
doch allen geht es laut bayerischen
gesundheitsministerium gut sorgen macht
sich die wirtschaft große unternehmen
beschränken ihre kontakte mit china
zumindest was reisen betrifft auch die
fluggesellschaften lufthansa inklusive
ziehen konsequenzen
christoph distel flughafen frankfurt von
hier nach china das geht schon noch aber
erstmal nicht mit der lufthansa für
anderthalb wochen streicht sie alle
flüge aus operativen gründen heißt es
knapp
gleichzeitig bereitet sich der flughafen
auf eine sondermaschine aus china vor
morgen wohl sie landen an bord rund 100
deutsche die raus wollen aus der
krisenregion mit ihnen vielleicht aber
auch dass corona virus eine
herausforderung für die verantwortlichen
wir werden sie nach den gängigen
verfahren aber dann wahrscheinlich auch
zentral betreuen und auch versorgen
klartext zwei wochen quarantäne für alle
also ähnliches verfahren wie in der
münchner klinik in der die vier
bayerischen corona patienten isoliert
liegen die sich alle bei einer
chinesischen kollegen angesteckt hatten
drei männer eine frau ohne vorerkrankung
er jung und entsprechend ihr bildet er
jetzt alles bestens die vier sind pumpe
gesund also haben keine symptomatik sind
fieberfrei husten nicht
denen ist so langweilig dass sie uns
ständig mit der entlassfeier nerven
auch in ihrer firma webasto die
drängende frage wann ist das virus
wirklich weg vorerst bleibt der betrieb
geschlossen und wer kann arbeitet von zu
hause corona stoppen für viele deutsche
unternehmen wie etwa schott in mainz
wird es gerade zu einer
riesenherausforderung wenn nach china
exportiert und dort auch produziert
kommt dauernd in kontakt persönlich
körperlich plötzlich ist das tabu wir
versuchen natürlich meetings die
abgesagt werden über skype oder
telefonkonferenzen aufrecht zu erhalten
wir versuchen versuche besucher zu
verschieben dazu das angebot an
mitarbeiter in china
wer nach hause will wird heimgeholt so
halten es die meisten betroffenen firmen
in deutschland wer bleiben will für den
hat schott eine art notfallpaket
desinfektion mundschutz
fieberthermometer produkte eigentlich
aus china importiert aber die sind dort
derzeit unmöglich zu bekommen
schauen wir nach china in das land aus
dem das virus kommt
dort steigt die zahl der erkrankten
rasant innerhalb eines tages um ein
drittel auf jetzt fast 6000 infizierte
zum vergleich das verwandte sars virus
die lungenkrankheit verbreitete sich in
den jahren 2002 und 2003 sie kam
ebenfalls aus china
insgesamt stecken sich mehr als 8000
menschen an 774 starben
die ausbreitung damals deutlich weniger
rasant als heute entsprechend hoch ist
die nervosität in china ulf röller
china greift zu drastischen maßnahmen im
kampf gegen das virus
das geht einfach nicht stark aus du hast
38,3 temperatur
wir sind in einem vorort von peking wie
hier gibt es in der ganzen hauptstadt
kontrollstationen die den weg in die
wohngebiete absperren mit fieber darf
niemand mehr zu seiner wohnung
was machen die die sie nicht durchlassen
ob sie ins krankenhaus gehen ist ihre
entscheidung
sie arbeiten tag und nacht in acht
stunden schichten das virus verbreitet
angst in vielen siedlungen rund um die
hauptstadt auf dem banner steht wir
besiegen die seuche wir wollen den ort
schützen wir sagen jedem der von
außerhalb kommt dass er nicht rein der
hoffentlich können wir unseren bewohnern
und dem land 22 millionen leben in der
hauptstadt aber sie wirkt ausgestorben
die behörden lägen die stadt lahm wollen
keine menschenmenge man soll mundschutz
tragen wenn man rausgeht und sich oft
die hände waschen
ich mache mir aber sorgen bald geht sie
nach hause
dann sind chinas straßen wieder leer und
nur noch die abend dekoration zum
neujahrsfest erinnert daran dass das
land um diese zeit eigentlich feiert
und eine ausführliche reportage über die
situation in china sehen sie um 22 15 im
zdf auslandsjournal weitere hintergründe
über das corona virus die symptome und
die ansteckungsgefahr finden sie
zusammengefasst auf heute.de jedes jahr
um den tag der befreiung von auschwitz
erinnert auch der bundestag an die
millionen opfer des nationalsozialismus
heute aber war dieses gedenken ein
besonderes nicht nur wegen des 75
jahrestags sondern auch weil diesmal
neben dem deutschen auch der israelische
staatspräsident sprach und der betonte
neben mahnenden worten vor allem auch
den geist von freundschaft und
versöhnung
andreas ruppert liga ein wiegenlied
geschrieben von der jüdischen
schriftstellerin ilse wie sie soll das
lied in auschwitz für ihren sohn und
andere kinder gesungen haben auf dem weg
in die gaskammer der musikalische rahmen
lässt die erinnerungen an die nazi
gräuel lebendig werden erinnerungen die
nie in vergessenheit geraten dürfen so
wolfgang schäuble ja immer wieder
versuche es gibt sie immer noch das
verbrechen kleinzureden oder umzudeuten
das wird nicht gelingen
der deutsche bundespräsident mahnt in
anwesenheit des israelischen präsidenten
rieflin dass die bösen geister der
vergangenheit sich heute in neuem gewand
zeigt wachsende antisemitismus
fremdenfeindlichkeit völkisches denken
und nicht zuletzt der anschlag auf die
synagoge in halle seien indizien dafür
kämpfen wir gegen antisemitismus gegen
rassenhass und nationale alpha erlegen
wir nicht der verführung des autoritären
streiten wir mit argumenten nicht mit
hass präsident rief linz all dem
deutschen engagement lob im kampf gegen
fremdenhass und antisemitismus denn auch
75 jahre nach auschwitz ist die gefahr
weiter präsent es ist kein kampf den man
mit einem schlag gewinnen kann
wir dürfen nicht aufgeben wir dürfen
nicht nachlassen deutschland darf hier
nicht versagt
wehret den anfängen gemeinsam gegen
antisemitismus so der
deutsch-israelische appel
anlässlich der holocaust gedenkfeier im
bundestag eine bitte hatte präsident
wölfli noch an deutschland es solle
vermitteln im konflikt mit den
palästinensern
der so genannte friedensplan für nahost
des amerikanischen präsidenten könne
neue gespräche möglich machen
das sehen viele palästinenser anders
tausende protestierten gegen die
bedingungen des tram plans sowie den
ausschluss ihres präsidenten abbas von
den verhandlungen
die palästinenser fordern einen
souveränen staat mit ganz ost-jerusalem
als hauptstadt schwächephase überwunden
es geht mit der wirtschaft in
deutschland allmählich wieder aufwärts
sagt wirtschaftsminister altmaier
für dieses jahr rechnet er mit einem
wachstum von 1,1 prozent etwas mehr als
bei der letzten prognose im herbst für
das vergangene jahr hatte das
statistische bundesamt 0,6 prozent des
wirtschaftswachstums ermittelt aufwärts
geht es auch mit den mindestlöhnen in
der altenpflege sie sollen in den
kommenden zwei jahren schrittweise
steigen
unterschieden wird künftig nach
qualifikation demnach bekommen ab april
2022 pflegehilfskräfte 12 euro 5 und 5
sich qualifizierte hilfskräfte also
solche mit einjähriger ausbildung
mindestens 13 euro 20 für
pflegefachkräfte steigt der mindestlohn
dann auf 15 eur 40 überraschende
personalrochade bei der berliner spd
bundesfamilienministerin franziska
giffey will bürgermeister michael müller
ablösen
geplant ist eine neue doppelspitze die
41 jährige soll zusammen mit dem
fraktionsvorsitzenden riley co
parteichefin werden und möglicherweise
im herbst 2021 spitzenkandidatin für das
amt der regierenden bürgermeisterin
markus groß berichtet michael müller
will nicht mehr will nicht mehr berlins
spd-chef sein
für ihn ist es eine art befreiungsschlag
und eine reaktion auf die derzeitigen
schlechten umfragewerte nun soll ein
neues duo die hauptstadt spd aus dem
tief führen
fraktionschef reiz allee und
familienministerin franziska giffey
insofern glaube ich haben wir da jetzt
eine gute möglichkeit auch in verteilten
rollen auf mehreren schultern
verantwortung zu übernehmen weiter
verantwortung zu tragen für die berliner
spd und uns wirklich gut aufzustellen
für die themen die jetzt auch anstehen
schon lange wurde über eine
personalveränderung spekuliert auf dem
landesparteitag im mai soll die neue
führungsspitze installiert werden vor
allem familienministerin gipfel gilt
seit langem als hoffnungsträgerin die
krise um ihre doktorarbeit ist vorüber
nun sei sie bereit für neue aufgaben
sagt sie ich habe lust in berlin und mit
der berliner spd
das zusammen zu machen und das wird gut
ich sage ihnen michael müller gibt den
spd-vorsitz auf will aber bis zum
nächsten herbst regierungschef bleiben
auch wenn es heute keine offizielle
festlegung gab dass franziska giffey im
kommenden wahlkampf spitzenkandidatin
wird ist mehr als wahrscheinlich
lange wurde um den kohleausstieg
gerungen jetzt soll er zum gesetz werden
das kabinett hat den entwurf
verabschiedet wonach alle deutschen
kohlekraftwerke bis spätestens 2008 und
30 abgeschaltet werden für deren
betreiber ihre beschäftigten und die
betroffenen regionen sind
entschädigungen in milliardenhöhe
vorgesehen umweltschutz sehr kritisieren
den ausstieg als zu langsam und fordern
nachbesserungen bis mitte des jahres
soll das gesetz durch den bundestag
das bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig
hat heute über das verbot der
internetplattformen links unten in die
media verhandelt fünf mutmaßliche
betreiber der plattform hatten gegen das
verbot geklagt wollten sich aber nicht
als betreiber zu erkennen geben
deshalb ist die zulässigkeit der klage
umstritten
eine entscheidung der richter steht noch
aus die seite galt als wichtigstes forum
auch für gewaltbereite linksextremisten
sie wurde 2017 verboten nach dem schier
endlosen hin und her wird der brh exit
in gut zwei tagen nun tatsächlich
realität das eu parlament machte den weg
für den abschied großbritanniens aus der
europäischen union frei die abgeordneten
gaben vor wenigen minuten ihren segen
und stimmten dem brh exit vertrag zu von
einer sitzung voller emotionen berichtet
aus brüssel in bonn
in der sozialdemokratischen fraktion des
europaparlaments singen sie am mittag
ein altes schottisches liters in der
deutschen übersetzung bekannt ist unter
dem titel
nehmt abschied brüder und verabschieden
sich so von den labour-abgeordneten da
fließen die ersten tränen der tag den
wir niemals erleben wollten wird kommen
es fühlt sich an als hätte man mich auf
dieser seite des kanals im exil zurück
gelassen
als hätte mich mein land verlassen das
ist wirklich sehr traurig auch könnten
darling wird das parlament verlassen sie
hatte in den letzten tagen schon gepackt
sechs jahre europapolitik träume und
hoffnungen wandern in kisten noch keine
neue partnerschaft wird die vorzüge
einer mitgliedschaft bringen aber wir
haben die pflicht das beste für die
britischen und europäischen menschen in
der nacht wechsels anzustreben mahnt die
kommissionspräsidentin dragset vorreiter
nigel farage hingegen feiert nur wenige
tage noch dann ist vollbracht wofür er
jahrelang gekämpft hat ich weiß ihr
werdet uns vermissen und wollte unsere
nationale flagge verbannen aber wir
winken euch zum abschied das parlament
will einen ungeordneten dragset
vermeiden billig darum mit großer
mehrheit dem brett vertrag und besiegelt
den austritt großbritanniens am 31 erst
fast das ganze plenum sinkt nimmt
abschied brüder
traurig aber jetzt zum spaten arbeit und
da steht alexander zverev bei den
australian open so weit ist der
hamburger bei einem grand slam turnier
noch nie gekommen
der 22 jährige zeigte sich in glänzender
form und trifft übermorgen auf den
österreicher dominik team der heute in
seinem viertelfinalspiel den
weltranglisten ersten rafael nadal
schlug alexanders wäre verliert den
ersten satz eins zu sechs dann hat er
sich an seinen gegner war brinker und
die hitzebedingt schneller fliegende
bälle gewöhnt gewinnt das aufschlagspiel
des dreimaligen grand slam siegers 6 3
im zweiten satz der ausgleich hat nur
den modus der letzten spiele
wiedergefunden hetzt seinen zwölf jahre
älteren gegner über den platz und
gewinnt auch den nächsten satz mit 6 zu
beim matchball überrascht dass seine
gegner serve und volley nach dem zweiten
aufschlag wawrinkas return im aus
endlich steht zverev auch bei einem
grand slam turnier unter den letzten
vier
ich bin natürlich unglaublich froh dass
ich heute die menschen gehabt habe und
jetzt im halbfinale stehe wo ich weiß
auch dass es nicht vorbei ist nächster
gegner der österreicher dominik team mit
6 zu 2 siegen vorn in der internen
bilanz doch diesem alexander zverev ist
jetzt alles zuzutrauen
zur fußball bundesliga fortuna feiert
friedhelm funkel
der tabellenletzte aus düsseldorf trennt
sich von dem bei den fans so beliebten
trainer und setzt im abstiegskampf auf
uwe rösler als neuen coach uwe rösler
ist als trainer neu in der bundesliga
friedhelm funkel geht als trainer
urgestein nach vier jahren in düsseldorf
hinterlässt große fußstapfen und ich
versuche natürlich mit der mannschaft
mit dem funktionsteam und mit den ganzen
verein geschichte zu schreiben indem wir
die klasse halten
rösler hat vereine in norwegen england
und schweden trainiert funkels laufbahn
als trainer in der bundesliga endet nach
mehr als 500 spielen da gibt es nichts
dran zu rücken
was ist mit anderen worten meine
trainerkarriere ist beendet röslers
erstes spiel mit der fortuna samstag
gegen eintracht frankfurt
und das war's auch schon von mir danken
arbeit und wir haben noch eine nette
geschichte zum schluss aus dem berliner
zoo
das sind fit und paule wie sie ihre
pfleger nennen mit ihrer mama mengen
menge die junge panda familie bei ihrem
ersten gemeinsamen ausflug in panda
garten
ab morgen können alle zur besucher die
zwillinge bewundern bit und paule kam
letztes jahr im august zur welt der
erste panda nachwuchs überhaupt in
deutschland
sympathische sippe und hier kommen noch
die lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen lauten
17 22 24 39 48 49 und die superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
das wetter beruhigt sich ab morgen
wieder nach sturm und schnee und wird
zum wochenende deutlich milder
mehr zu den aussichten gleich von katja
honnefer so viel an diesem mittwoch von
uns claus kleber begrüßt sie um 21 uhr
45 und an dieser stelle freut sich
morgen christian sievers auf sie
danke für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen schönen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren nach
sturm nach orkan nach kräftigen regen
und schnee regen und graupelschauern ja
gewittern kommt jetzt langsam wieder ein
bisschen ruhe ins wetter heute zeigte
sich ja zwischendurch auch durchaus mal
die sonne gestern nacht allerdings fiel
zum beispiel in hamburg ein zentimeter
schnee
heute nacht gibt es zwei regen und
schneeregen schwerpunkte zum einen hier
im norden ziehen mit diesem stürmischen
wind einige regenwolken über uns hinweg
und das ist doch etwas schneeregen dabei
und es gibt noch schnee regen und
schneeschauer in bayern da kann es also
glatt sein aber nicht nur dort denn die
temperaturen sinken doch verbreitet auf
+3 bis -2 grad morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 4 grad im
thüringer wald und 12 grad im breisgau
und am vormittag regnet es nordöstlich
der elbe noch kräftig weiter
anfangs ist auch noch ein bisschen
schnee dabei sonst wird es ganz
freundlich das ändert sich am nachmittag
wenn nämlich hier westlich des rheins es
schon wieder neu anfängt zu regnen am
freundlichsten wird es morgen am
alpenrand seien und auch am freitag gibt
es dort die meiste sonne
es wird mild regnerisch und sehr windig
am wochenende aber die böden können den
regen gut gebrauchen
schönen abend noch